[Applaudissements]
cédric et roule agriculteurs jugée pour
avoir aidé des migrants il symbolise à
lui seul le combi de solidarité et je
suis heureux les avoir accueillis et je
suis fier a recueilli chez moi mais au
juste le délit de solidarité
c'est quoi robben qui est bien à vrai
dire ça n'existe pas enfin pas dans ton
côté j'y comprend une loi de 1930 huit
reprises à la libération en 1945
interdit l'aide directe ou indirecte à
la circulation ou au séjour irrégulier
d'étrangers
en clair faire traverser la frontière à
un migrant et bergères un migrant et des
nourrir assisté c'est non non et non
en 1996 exemple d'un procès pour délit
de solidarité
cette femme est jugée après avoir
hébergé un zaïrois
je suis sujette accusé d'avoir été trop
sympa en fait coupable mais dispensé de
peine car la loi est floue la loi tout
le monde
arnaud despléchin et une soixantaine de
cinéastes se mobilisent pendant cette
affaire et appelle à la désobéissance
civile
il les incite des aidants ceux qui
aident les migrants à continuer à
héberger et à nourrir à soigner
heureusement que ces personnes disent
c'est qui qui ouvre une petite pas parce
qu'au fond quand on y pense dans délit
de solidarité
il y a solidarité
et vite je crois que c'est pas bien une
contradiction quelque part qui a raison
qui a tort allez savoir
une injustice selon les aidants en tant
que passeur oui on doit le condamner oui
je dois être en prison oui on dois
m'arrêter qu'on arrêtait 5500 qu'ils le
font ok mais pas lésés dans cinq ans de
prison et 30 mille euros damende voilà
le risque encouru en réalité ils ne sont
pas souvent appelés devant les tribunaux
même le ministre de l'immigration de
l'époque le reconnaissait pour être
risquer d'être poursuivis en france il
faut être suspects de complicité être
entrée dans la chaîne de l'immigration
clandestine
il faut dire que faire des lois sur le
délit de solidarité n'est pas évident il
pas très bien à la vérité à chaque fois
le conseil constitutionnel retoque les
textes de manière à ne pas poursuivre
les actes humanitaires ou désintéressés
de toute façon depuis 2012 le délit de
solidarité autrement dit d'assistance
aux personnes en situation irrégulière
est supprimée fini des poursuites quand
il s'agit d'assurer la dignité ou
l'intégrité d'un migrant m'aider et
dansant poursuivi car plus militants que
humanitaire selon les autorités
bilan des courses en 30 ans environ 60
procès et 40 condamnation pour délit de
solidarité
[Musique]